actor Tom Hardy often portrays
characters that are dangerous cold and
calculating that makes him the perfect
choice to play venom the slimy antihero
at the center of Marvel's spider-man
spin-off party seems to have the ability
to physically transform himself for any
role here's a rundown of his most
remarkable transformations over the
years all of which helped him get the
physique necessary to play venom
dropping wait for Stewart Tom Hardy is
far from a natural athlete he's admitted
to feeling small and skinny and
vulnerable as a child and was
intimidated by the gym because of all
the testosterone his first dedicated
physical transformation began with the
2007 biopic Stewart a life backwards
party lost a whole lot of weight to
portray Stewart shorter a homeless
heroin addict with muscular dystrophy he
lost almost 30 pounds for the role but
took a relatively healthy approach to
his body transformation party worked
with a personal trainer ran several
miles a day and kept a diet rich in
protein including eating as much spinach
and greens as he wanted fortunately for
his sanity the training and diet regimen
only lasted five or six weeks bulking up
for Bronson when he began training for
the lead role in Bronson already needed
to pack on serious weight
he told I loved film probably weight
about 11 stone would like just with
those in my pocket to play the
notoriously violent criminal heart he
only had five weeks to bulk up using a
bare-bones workout routine Hardy managed
to miraculously put on seven pounds a
week his trainer ex-marine Patrick
peanut Monroe added lots of variations
to his workouts making every rep
difficult in one way or another
you had four walls and floor up beam
intensity for warrior for his next film
warrior Tom Hardy demonstrated
impressive discipline while preparing
for his role as a marine turned MMA
fighter Rd packed on slabs of lean
muscle to convincingly portray a
professional athlete and his daily
training regimen was tough he even
lifted weights with his teeth to build
neck muscles you heard that right so it
was like two hours blokes hidden to us
kickboxing hazing my tie and two hours
choreography a day and then two hours
lifted every day the actor ate five or
six high-protein meals per day and wound
up 29 pounds heavier than when he
trained for Bronson beefing up for Bain
to play the masked villain Bain in the
Dark Knight Rises Hardy needed to appear
larger than life which he achieved by
packing on even more size prior to
shooting party appeared on chatty man
and opened up about the physical demands
of the role he gotta get it up to about
13 or 14 stone 12 in a bit now so ago
and three months to do that how did you
felt calm but laugh at packing on 30
pounds brought Hardy's weight up
considerably he was almost 200 pounds by
the time filming began but as he told
Jonathan Ross that still wasn't enough
to intimidate Christian Bale on the
first day of shooting and I looked at my
news of Timmy like oh yeah
losing mass formats in order to play the
title character in Mad Max fury road
party had to lose 30 pounds the same
amount of weight he gained to play bane
he told Collider he wanted to look like
a hungry wolf or like when you put a cat
in the bath party reached his goal in a
surprising way by smoking cigarettes and
eating only one meal per day once the
weight was dropped the next step was
three or four months of fight training
party didn't exactly have time to rest
when cameras were rolling either he told
Men's Fitness and it's a very physical
shoot from the beginning from the
training right through to the six months
of shooting on the ground finding his
inner venom by the time venom started
filming in October 2017 party was
already a master at transforming his
body he got ripped for the role by
applying tools he'd accumulated over
years of hard work with no quick fix or
magic and breeding he required guidance
from professional MMA fighter Nathan
Jones and personal trainer Marc mean and
trained in a combination of boxing MMA
and kickboxing he's a good student
perceptive to London judging from a
sparring video Jones posted on Instagram
Hardy adapted to the challenge quickly
listen I'm just setting the time Tommy's
doing wha Hardy's got a lot to live up
to given Venom's reputation but
considering the actors ability to fully
commit to a role there should be no
doubts Peter Parker look out
[Music]